the entertainment world was stunned on
Saturday by the death of sitcom star
Matthew Perry the actor who played
Chandler Bing and friends died on
Saturday October 28th 2023 at the age of
54 following the reports of Perry's
passing several stars from across the
industry began sharing their condolences
and their memories of Perry among those
Stars a Star Trek actor George teay who
tweeted his condolences for Perry's
family teay wrote what a tragic piece of
news to read my heart goes out to his
loved ones and longtime castmates Teen
Wolf and Yellowstone star Ian Bowen
tweeted holy Matthew Perry no fing
way meanwhile another '90s television
star also paid tribute to Perry Jason
Alexander who played George castanza on
Seinfeld tweeted his morning at the news
of Perry's death writing what a
wonderful and unique talent he will long
be remembered and cherished for the gift
of his work and sorely missed by so so
many